ils étaient unis dans cinq
circonscriptions des yvelines lors des
dernières élections législatives
communistes écologistes socialistes et
radicaux de gauche part divisée dans la
course aux sénatoriales
nelly duthu conduit la liste l'humain
d'abord du parti communiste avec en
point d'orgue la défense du progrès
social
aujourd'hui on ne peut que constater cno
nos projets ne sont pas encore assez
commun notre objectif n'est pas encore
assez comment pour avoir trouvé la
candidature commune
même constat pour l'ancien député
écologiste de la 10e circonscription des
yvelines entre 2010 et 2012
anny poursinoff elle présente la liste
europe écologie les verts dans ces
élections sénatoriales
chacun va être sur ses positions garder
la tête de liste ia qu'un élu ça doit
être moi et chaque à dix ans ça on est
dans une impasse c'est triste mais c'est
comme ça et puis bon par ailleurs ça
permet aussi de
mieux connaître les convictions des uns
et des autres c'est vrai que
l'écologiste c'est quand même quelque
chose de très différent du reste des
programmes de
nos collègues pour le parti socialiste
la liste unie à gauche pour les yvelines
sera conduite par sandrine grand gang
objectif obtenir au moins un siège de
sénateur le parti socialiste reste le
parti qui a le plus d'élus à gauche dans
ce département
donc nous on appelle l'ensemble des élus
à s'ils veulent qui est une vraie
pluralité au sénat qu'ils veulent que
vraiment on puisse avoir un vrai débat
démocratique et que la gauche soit
représenté il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'autres possibilités que de renforcer
la liste que je présente de son côté le
prg présente une liste de rassemblement
de la gauche des écologistes du centre
et des indépendants
nous avions des réserves vis-à-vis du
gouvernement nous avions des réserves
vis-à-vis des positions exprimées par
une partie de la gauche
puis nous avons notre propre identité
mais nous sommes pas seuls le prg
puisque nous avons rassemblé quatre
autres partis autour de nous et nous
souhaitons que cette gauche cette
ouverture au centre soit aujourd'hui
représenté visible mais aussi et surtout
entendu par les élus du territoire
le risque de cette division la gauche
pourrait perdre les deux sièges détenus
jusqu'à maintenant
catherine tasca décidé de ne pas briguer
un nouveau mandat
philippe esnol lui présente une liste
composée d'élus locaux de centre droit à
noter enfin aucune candidature de la
france insoumise a été présenté dans les
yvelines dans le cadre de ce scrutin